welcome to this video playing Dr calm
this is Denny Coppedge right yep I am
yeah mmm-hmm okay let's see
no it's going for a queen pawn queen
pawn game here
Tori attack never thought that this is
very dangerous but we're going to see
what happens mm d6 okay let's let's go
with d5 just very classical approach
putting pawns in the center can rarely
be bad it looks a little bit like a
French I just have the Queen on f6 okay
I'm going to put the Queen back it takes
a little bit of time this obviously but
at least I've got them the pair of
Bishops long term okay what he's going
to do yeah I wonder he's staying
flexible with them with castling
yeah I mean it was like c5 I'm very much
underdeveloped I'm not sure I want to
castle shorter his his he's getting an
attack I have aged six plate
yeah I'm not sure how to how to set up
my pieces here absolutely not
Oh another sis alike actually that he is
declaring his intentions in the in the
center ok my night is misplaced now it
really wants to be on c6 in this
position but still still I like it that
I know what's happening in the center
who came don't be one okay it's not
going to it's not going to Castle long
anymore and I'm going to spend lots of
time now to regroup my knight and maybe
you can take with the noid hmm now maybe
I should have played night b8 first yeah
it looks very slow but the knight on the
seventh is so misplaced I have to have
to reroute that okay can I even spend
even more time here snatching a pawn on
a2 or the bishop pair I will do that it
takes ages but the position in the
center is completely closed so I'm not
going to get checkmated by some some
tactic or anything now that looks ok I'm
pretty satisfied with this position he
can also I don't think he can sacrifice
a pawn yellow like we should be too
I will take a two this is this is ok
yeah and that's that that's my bishop
there okay so I can't cancel now finally
now that the king is saved there there's
no light squared bishop anymore in
particular which is very important this
is the bishop that normally helps you or
helps Wyatt to to checkmate black okay
so he's going for this to do this here
trying to trade Queens and prepare b6 I
want b6 covering c5 yep
so his night on b3 is not doing that
much
to bishops against two knights is
normally very very favorable check but
it's very close disposition so not not
something that is easily exploited let's
see I am probably I have to go with with
something with a5 playing against those
exposed pawns yeah I was I was just
seeing that Queen Bromley trying to come
to c7 if I'd go to d7 with the bishop
he's got Queen c7 it's a bit annoying
okay it's not ideal but Jam maybe can go
a 4 B 5 now this kind of thing but that
that I didn't play well
really
that's surprising I don't really think
that this helps him very much
yeah getting the C file
I mean trading I don't think he can
allow can do that so he has to give me
the invasions class oh he just trade oh
I would have thought that this is really
not possible long-term I go to B 5 and
then a 5 and white falls is falling
apart I think
okay so let's see dwell how do i play
that do I take on a three for Bishop b4
check yeah probably
oh if I take a five king bee - it's that
something great then yeah I think this
is better right
he takes b6 I give the check and now his
Knights are tied together
let's see checking here a [ __ ] f5 oh
how am I going to do that this is also
not bad and wonder if I should do g6
on if this is important not trying let's
let's do it let's do that
it's not so easy my still fairly solid
him maybe has a kind of kind of a
fortress in yeah possibly
maybe he has a fortress no I don't have
a good square for this
that's really pretty ashamed what a good
position yeah this is not this is
unfortunately not not winnable it looks
nice but you cannot you cannot win this
you can just just shuffle around offered
gras offered
yeah that's a shame this is a game you
really must win with this big an
advantage yeah maybe maybe it is it is
somehow somehow holding but probably
this was the problem that is that
allowed
I allowed this business here so this one
normally white is getting Zuke's one
tear somehow with them against the
bishops some some somewhere I have to
try to invade should be for that's not
so easy to analyze Bishop to e4 Bishop I
don't get them check now it's not so
easy this is totally totally symmetrical
maybe maybe I have to time it a little
bit better
I mean it's not threatening anything
here maybe I should take some time or
arm or wait what about still about this
let's check this and I can actually take
so he has to do this
yeah that's not so clear yeah maybe
maybe I should have kept Queens on I
don't know I mean I am I should win this
somehow but I'm not I'm not totally
convinced how to do it check this looks
excellent but maybe there is no real win
a completely different setup that I need
to take
this I don't know you probably cannot
take ever these nights I are very much
dominated here here six
and it looks excellent
but is this winning I'm not completely
sure beginning to see - and then
combining Bishop b2 ideas with the
attack on D form and it probably wins
but not so easy okay well thanks for
watching